Tristan first of all your reaction to
that extraordinary interview I just
finish with your brother I think that
was one of the best interviews ever
conducted with Andrew I actually I don't
know how hard you're going to go on me
so perhaps I'm making a mistake saying
this I I like how you challenge your
guests I like how you seem to have a
very impartial opinion on people you
don't judge things one way or another
before you go into the interviews and I
think that made the interview with
Andrew very interesting I'm I'm very
excited to see the public response I
mean like I said to him I'm not here to
to convict you or otherwise I don't know
if you're guilty or not of the charges
LED against you will establish that in a
trial or otherwise I mean it may not
even go to trial no it might not I mean
it seems to me there's been an
interesting relaxing of restrictions
against you and your brother really from
the time you were put in prison at the
start of the year what do you read into
that well if you understand how the
Romanian justice system works again I
have to be very careful what I say the
pressure to put us in jail comes from
not organizations there are many great
people who work organizations like decot
which is the organization investigating
us but it comes from individuals
individual prosecutors who I am very
much a trophy for I would say so the the
absolute obsession with putting me in
jail comes from these people but these
people have nothing to do with judges
you see at the end of the day if you
investigate me for a year and a half
throw me in jail drag my name through
the mud eventually you're going to have
to come up with a file of evidence and
show it to a judge so the people who
keep letting me go are the people who've
seen that file of evidence and don't
have a motivation to keep me in jail so
that's it broken down as simply as I can
in the BBC report of the prosecution
files the quote you were saying about
the women who worked on your webcam
business I'm going to slave these
I'm going to make them work even
more hours and hours and hours I work
these like slaves slave work
minimum 10 or 12 hours a day that is not
true at all so you never said that um no
well you said it sarcastically no I
didn't say it sarcastically at all that
is about my ex-girlfriend cleaning my
house so what you have to understand is
when you go through a man's phone you
have four years and hundreds of
thousands millions of messages to
everyone he's ever spoken to now this is
about human trafficking my my um
accusation so anyone coerced anyone
forced anyone tied up anyone kidnapped
anyone sold anyone moved none of that is
in any of my WhatsApp conversations but
decot and the prosecutor essentially can
eliminate parts of the conversation that
he says are not relevant now if you look
at the timings between the messages and
all these conversations that look very
bad he's deleting various things a lot
of lol's and a lot of hahas because
believe me if you were to read mine and
my brother's conversations even right
now you could probably accuse me of
conspiracy to commit murder because the
stupid things that we talk about I was
talking about to commit murder I mean
Andrew I'm going to kill you when I get
home like things like this which can be
used you know in a very negative way you
accept you've used language about oh
loads I've used I've used worse language
that so but how do you feel about that
now it's all been laid bad well it's
very unfortunate that I think this
conversation is 3 years old I think our
house was messy after a party and I was
saying oh yeah she's my slave don't
worry I'll get her working um way you do
you regret using language like that no I
don't because really
well last week my daughter's mother sent
me a photo of her drawing on the wall
with crayons and I said hahaa I'm going
to kill her when I get home now you
could delete the hah haa because you
feel that's irrelevant because you're
the prosecutor and you can arrest me and
all my friends and throw me in jail for
conspiracy to commit the murder of
children you could do that if you wish
i' ask not the way I meant it but I'd
ask a different question I would say
when your daughter grows up yes how
would you like it if another man spoke
about your daughter by saying I'm going
to slave the I'm going to make her
work even more hours and hours I work
this like a slave if someone said
that and you saw it actually in a
message they sent about your daughter
how would you feel well that's not the
best message to have sent and you know
there's lots of lock
talk I regret you regret it or you don't
I no I don't I regret that it became
public because you know the way men
speak to each other if I were to go
through all of your WhatsApp messages I
don't know what I'd find it you wouldn't
mind if if a man spoke that way about
your daughter when she's older you
wouldn't mind or you would mind of
course I would mind but it depends on
the context of the relationship you
think disrespect the girl I was talking
about cleaning my house at the time I'm
no longer with her and also this
conversation is not about anyone who's
listed as a victim in the file which is
a very important distinction to make the
girl I was talking about I wasn't very I
was very in love with at the time I had
a very great relationship with at the
time you know if you say to your
girlfriend oh come here I'm going to
spank you that's not you know if you if
you're her coworker or you're a man who
stalking her it's a very different
context if you're her boyfriend the
problem is that in the context of what
you've been accused of yes the
prosecutor can make it look bad this
looks damning of course but what he
doesn't do is he doesn't show the whole
conversations to any judge that is a
carefully manipulated and edited and
actually constructed conversation as all
of the conversations are this whole
lover boy thing right the the suggestion
is that you and Andrew basically you're
two good-looking fast talkinging Smart
Guys right and you've you know had
plenty of money and you've enjoyed
yourselves fine yes and that you've
managed to deliberately or otherwise but
the suggestion is deliberately persuade
a lot of women to fall in love with you
very quickly and then you use that
relationship and how they feel about you
to then guide them towards making money
from webcam well that's interesting um
of the seven women that you've listed
none of them or none of which we can
name do you know how many of them ever
worked at my old webcaming business I
had many years ago of the seven victims
listed how many of them were in any way
related to any of the activities I did
when I ran a webcam Studio the answer
pie years you'd be surprised to know is
zero people on the internet I call them
Twitter detectives not the police not
Deon not even this over ambitious
prosecutor because there are webcam
Studios all over the city has tried to
make any criminal complaint about that
small business that me and Andrew as he
said dipped our toe in I Was Made Me
running it to be fair all those years
ago none of these people who are are
alleged victims today have anything to
do with the webcam Studio but if you
watch Clips on Twitter when we speak as
a 24-year-old vulgarly oh yeah you know
I'm I'm I'm pimping cuz I'm in the club
with a bunch of girls you know when we
speak that way it's easy to say ah look
he's admitted he's confessed to his
crimes the old webcam studio and the
current investigation have zero strings
in between them so the question in of
itself doesn't make sense if you
understand
that you could face further time in jail
if you're convicted yes of these
offenses a long time in jail you were in
jail earlier this year what was that
experience like for you jail was you
know when you're going through something
really difficult and it's almost
unbearable whether it be a difficult gym
session or you know a major setback and
you come out after it's finished and the
moment it ends you're like yeah I'm glad
that happened jail was hell every single
day but the moment we got that phone
call saying a judge who's now seen the
evidence that they've allegedly raised
against you um has decided to to release
you I was very happy for the experience
I'm very happy I spent three months
living in those conditions what did you
find out about yourself
I didn't find out anything new I feel
like it was my opportunity to show to
myself and to my brother and to the
world that I am the man who I say I am I
always preach being mentally strong
physically strong uh you know I put on
this tough guy persona but I don't think
he a tough guy persona because if I can
survive three months in a Romanian
prison without incident without tears
without being upset you didn't shed any
tears I did not in jail did you know
that Andrew had I believe that Andrew's
tears were tears of anger was more Angry
than I was whereas me and Andrew are
very balanced we have a very balanced
relationship we keep each other in check
when he's angry I calm him down when I'm
angry he calms me down I believe Andrew
was a lot angrier at the situation
Andrew knew a lot less about the
situation I can at least read some
Romanian I was trying to make sense of
it all he was sitting there in pure
frustration um for they're serious
criminal charges well they're serious
criminal charges but what I would say to
you is what is the serious criminal
evidence so again this is from the
I'm going to work this for hours it's
about a girl cleaning my house by the
way so this is the big bombshell the BBC
because I don't know how they got the
indictment but the indictment should be
private I'd love to give you a copy I
really would but the criminal indictment
isn't what the prosecutor says I've done
it's the evidence against me so if the
BBC have read their grubby little
fingers through all of this evidence and
all the files and the worst thing they
have to come at me with is ah Tristan
you said this girl's your slave I've
said that I've said worse things have
you ever coerced women no I've never
coerced anybody into doing anything they
don't like do you ex as I said to Andrew
that some of the language even in the
things he tweets now suggests that his
idea of how women should be treated is
that they effectively are a form of
slave to a man you know Pierce I really
like you and I sometimes feel you you
fall for Andrew's little traps and it's
really wonderful to watch because it's
not the things he says it's the way he
says them and the way he says them can
get people very riled up when I was
sitting listening to your interview
about women shouldn't work and be taken
care of Etc it actually sh took me back
about 12 or 13 years to an interview I
saw I can't remember I think it was on
ITV with the late Christopher Hitchens
you probably knew him did I did not know
Christopher Hitchens I was I was I think
he died way before I became relevant but
he was sitting there with this female
journalist and he's saying he his exact
words were oh I don't want Mrs Hitchens
to be coarsened in the labor market why
would I want my women courson in the
labor market no if she's with me she can
work if she wants but she doesn't have
to now he was not labeled the world's
biggest misogynist he was actually
hailed as an intellectual in this time I
read all of his books I used to be a a
big fan of his but um he said exactly
the same thing Andrew said exactly the
same thing with different intonations
and different tones and you probably
knew him you didn't attack him back then
for saying that did you but and judge he
could get people R Christ Vin is no
longer with us sadly a brilliant man in
many ways I disagree with him about many
things but he's not why I'm here
obviously yeah of course um you know it
just seems to me that the rhetoric
particularly by Andrew but also some of
the stuff they found with you the way
that you talk about women may be part of
the problem you found yourselves in here
and from Andrew's recent tweeting
there's no sign to me that he is is
aware or self-aware of quite how some of
this stuff comes over I understand and
that maybe that has been part of the
problem here with you guys well again
when you look at Andrew Tate and Tristan
Tate and you try to label Mis them
misogynist you gender the argument if I
were accused of anything else and they
were to read the conversations which
they did read by the way between me and
my friends the insults we give each
other the threats we make to each other
do you think a woman's place is at home
serving her man um I no no no I believe
my woman's place is at home serving her
family I serve my family she should go
to work we Ser she wouldn't have to if
if do if if if I wanted her to and she
wanted to and we agreed as a you wanted
her to if we agreed as a family what if
you don't want her to but she does well
in the same way that if I was working a
normal job and I got a promotion that
would that would mean that I move out of
the City or we move as a family we'd sit
there and discuss it as a family I don't
believe that there's one rule for every
single family I don't see Andrew Andrew
does I don't see in the future of my
woman working no because I think I could
take care of my woman I could take care
of my you wouldn't be I don't think
you'd be with a woman who wanted to work
right I've been with women who worked
and how did that go wonderfully I've had
some absolutely wonderful relationships
well doesn't that prove the point that
that's this whole idea a woman has to
stay at home and serve her man is
actually a lot of cobblers again I don't
think serve her man was uh was something
Andrew specifically said I would he did
I mean I that's why I read that whole
tweet well Andrew is not me and I'm not
Andrew what I would say is a woman
serves her family are you different in
your outlook oh me and Andrew are very
different me and Andrew are very
different people rolling stone in a
profile uh said this about Rolling Stone
their relationship Dynamic is very odd
it's like Tristan is held captive by
Andrew and believes or follows
everything Andrew says or does I don't
believe or follow a lot of things that
Andrew says or does um you know I get
asked every single day to counter EJ
Dickinson is This Woman's name I could
tell you some horrible stories about the
people who she's harassed and bothered
this Rolling Stone woman um the things
Andrew says and does I mean I get asked
what don't you like about his views what
the the major one the major one when
people say oh Tristan now that you've
converted to Islam I'm like I haven't
converted to Islam who says I converted
to Islam No I'm an Orthodox Christian
I've have not converted to Islam what do
you think of his conversion I think that
it's a it's not my place to even comment
on it now some of the greatest religious
discussions I've have had have been with
Andrew since his reversion since him
reading the Quran most of it of which he
covered in in prison and we sit there
and discuss these various ideas but I
believe that individual religious
conviction is exactly that it's
individual and I don't believe whether
I'm his brother whether I'm his son
mother Uncle I have no place to tell him
what his religious conviction should be
just as he has no business to tell me
mine so I'm I'm happy for him because
he's become a happier and better person
are you Rivals um yes oh absolutely but
in the best and most healthy way I can't
watch him train in the gym for an hour
in the morning and then not train for an
hour myself I can't sit there drinking
and relaxing and partying while he's on
his laptop working you ever fight no
never we never argue you never
physically fight oh we used to
physically fight all the time we're both
professional athletes so we used to beat
each other up in the in the ring for
sparring who would win oh Andrew would
win um I was good I was the European
champion at my Peak but Andrew was built
for Andrew's I mean see my broken nose
it leans this way first time it was
broken was by him and it got weaker
after that and I had it broken twice
subsequently in kickboxing matches but
yeah we we are rivals in the way that we
Inspire each other to work better and to
be better but not rivals in any way that
his success would upset me or my success
would upset him when you in jail
together yes so a period of that 3
months you were actually in the same
cell indeed for about half of it what
did you what did you talk about when
it's just you and him and you're
thinking we may never get out of
it ah lots of things books religion the
case obviously um explaining trying to
understand when you a cockroach infested
tiny cell together yes you've gone from
being the top G and his brother with
your Bugattis your cigars the the the
lifestyle the women and so on to
literally nothing in a very degrading
environment that you find yourself in
and you've got no idea how this plays
out or How It Ends or even if you get
out I mean that's a pretty that's a big
moment yeah I guess it's uh it is a big
moment but I always knew that we were
going to be okay you know even when I
was separate for him I wasn't worried
that he was banging his head against the
wall or self harming or doing anything
stupid again he wasn't worried about me
uh we obviously weren't worried that the
other brother and I know you can't share
in this conviction I know he's not a
criminal I know he has no skeletons in
his closet and no criminal past he knows
exactly the same about me so we were
very relaxed um I guess in jail I was
more relaxed than I am now because in
prison I assumed that the prosecutor
whose job by the Romanian Constitution
by the way he's not a district attorney
like in the United States where he is
told he has to argue that you're guilty
and that's it the prosecutor's job
actually here is to discern the truth of
the situation so obv sitting in jail
relatively relaxed well this is going to
end any day now I mean human trafficking
this is this is stupid it's not going to
happen like not going to sentence me to
jail for this it was only when I got out
that I learned the true motivations
behind this that made me actually more
worried than I was in jail so in jail I
was relatively relaxed trained every day
ate their horrible food did my push-ups
it was all right mental break no
electronics did your mother was she able
to come and see you or not no no in fact
could you speak to her for some reason
and I I cannot tell you why I was banned
from visitors that includes my daughter
the mother of my daughter that includes
any friends was Andrew as well um I
don't believe so but for No One tried to
visit him maybe they were rejected at
the prison gate I don't know but I was
at one point it's on file it's on
paperwork at one point I was banned from
receiving visitors could you make calls
uh there was some phone time but I
didn't make a single call while I was in
prison I spent three months without
speaking to anybody other than Andrew no
only my lawyer actually only my lawyer
and did you get into similar physical
threatening situations that he did no I
mean Andrew had like a few Mexican
standoffs let's say but I think that
jail is a world of realities and you
know lots of tough guys whether they be
Romanian or British or American nowadays
the tough guy move is you've offended me
I'm going to use my phone I'm going to
call the boys and the boys are going to
come beat you up I think that that is
the standard operating procedure in in
lots of the world I mean as Andrew said
I come from a council state I understand
this very well when you walk into a
prison cell that's not the reality the
reality is if I start a fight with this
guy it may be 10 to 15 minutes before
anyone shows up and I'm a 6'4 17 and a
half Stone former kickboxer everyone
knows me everyone knows I'm a
professional athlete so I actually
didn't have any problems at all I would
say that everyone was very kind and very
respectful to me not just because they
were intimidated by me no absolutely not
because there were some guys in there
who I should have been intimidated by
but I give respect and I I think I
receive it back and I I did I did okay
in that environment people often say and
it's certainly true from people I've
interviewed over the years that you're a
product of your environment particularly
of your parents yes in a November 2011
Facebook post your father Emory wrote
that the Eternal problem of the alpha
male was protecting his flock of women
he said but times I struck a woman
brackets in passion I never left a mark
no Trace hyper contr control super
control of a human animal they love me
still um I've never heard that before in
my life I'm smiling man cuz I can I can
imagine his voice saying it um you can I
can imagine his voice saying it the only
times I've struck a woman in Brackets in
passion have you ever struck a woman in
passion Pi no you haven't no not a
little
spank well once let's let's keep this
above board but I want to Pi but I'm
saying like I understand how you're
trying to phrase this no I my my father
is dead and no I'm I'm not I'm not
trying to phrase it in anyway I'm just
curious what you think you meant by that
um I I honestly don't know I mean keep
in mind my father died when I was 27 and
that post was written a long time ago
I've never heard it before I've never
seen it before what kind of father was
he in terms of the values he instilled
in you and Andrew oh he was a wonderful
man and he was a very protective man
over his family and the people he cared
about uh I mean they have't they they
got divorced many many years ago but
even with his dying breath he would have
jumped in to fight 10 men to defend my
mother and her honor um that's the kind
of guy he was super protective and super
you know involved in everyone he loves
life even if he was far away you know
the phone calls were were constant the
emails were constant and he held us very
accountable as young men Andrew tweeted
last year my dad was a chess genius CIA
operative my mother was a dinner lady
they had nothing in common dad said she
fed you boys healthy meals every day
cleaned the house and was largely quiet
I loved her very much that's literally
all men
want is that are you asking if that's an
accurate description of my parents
relationship perhaps yeah but my mother
was a wonderful mother see I don't I
don't think but they split they split up
of course of course they did but that
does well so when he says that's
literally all men one they split up way
before I was old enough to understand
marriage or sexual or male or female
Dynamics by the way so I can't even
comment on their marriage what I can
comment on is how they were as parents
and what I will say is I don't look back
on my childhood raised in a council
estate uh on state benefits you know I
was free school lunches I don't look
back on that and think oh my mother was
a terrible mother because we didn't have
any money because I don't think it was
my mother's job to to I guess provide as
much as my father was doing his best
from the United States but I will look
back and say my mother was an absolutely
wonderful mother I had three Square
meals a day um she knew how to M manage
her finances didn't smoke didn't go out
with her friends uh made sure my clothes
were always washed knew how to mend
things she was she is how does she feel
about the fact both her boys are in this
serious legal Jeopardy well you have to
understand she's known us our entire our
entire lives and you haven't you know
when I was 15 16 18 all my friends were
selling drugs and breaking into cars I
was down at the kickboxing gym every
single day I would get into the
kickboxing ring for 50s after 8 weeks
training just because I found Harmony in
the discipline that sport gave me I
think kickboxing is massively largely
responsible for keeping me from ever
doing anything illegal never tried a
drug in my life uh never broken a law in
my life never broken any law I was
speeding you know if you I mean we're
talking I'm talking about serious crimes
and my mother's known that even at my
most desperate and my most poor I would
come home to her and sleep on her counts
for 6 months as opposed to do anything
illegal and try to find an honest good
way of uh legal way at least of making
money so the idea she worried about you
the situation you're in well she's not
she's worried about the situation but
she has no no doubt in her mind that I
haven't done any heinous things against
women especially for money because it
doesn't make sense that after going
through what I've gone through and
avoiding any legal problems suddenly I'm
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and I decide that's the time to start
trafficking when you look at this whole
setup of the war room and the the
generals and the I think Andrew said
4,000 people are members now yes when I
saw the the web chat logs and so on he
says a lot of that isn't true I don't
know we'll have to wait and see whether
that's verified or not but a lot of the
language that's used seems to be that
people are being encouraged to spend all
this money to join a kind of cult where
they are encouraged to treat women as
second class citizens absolutely not
true one I don't that's what comes over
in these one I I I believe the
screenshots you've seen are fake one one
absolutely two I would say I'm a member
of the War Room the War Room has nothing
to do with me I'm just a war room member
like everybody else and I find lots of
great help within the war room within
whenever I want to do business with
somebody if I want to transfer money to
certain countries if I want to you know
find somebody who has talents that I
don't to recruit people to find people
to work for me that's what I use the War
Room for if you I don't think any
network in the world would exist where
men sit around and just complain about
women and and and try and treat Wom
women as second class citizens I mean
surely would compl I wouldn't want to
take part it's more like there one of
the running themes is to get the woman
to tattoo your name on herself I have
well that's that's clearly not true what
youve what you've read is fake and it's
made up by stupid journalists there's
12,000 pages of it there's 12,000 Pages
well it doesn't matter it's very easy to
find some chat logs and enter little
lines into it I don't think that it's
also very easy to say yeah a bit of it
was well here's well here's the thing if
4,000 people are talking across hundreds
of different rooms 24 hours a day right
now since the beginning of our inter
interview probably 300 400 messages have
been sent inside the war room I can't
tell you exactly what everyone has said
over the last four years and what they
haven't said I can't what I'm saying is
in my experience inside of the war room
that is absolutely not what the War Room
stands for that's not absolutely not
what the War Room teaches preaches what
anyone I know from the War Room believes
all the people I know from the War Room
are happily married men guys with
families Guys with Kids successful
businessmen people who run construction
companies real honest great people and
that does not represent us so I think
it's fake you guys have preached a
message of masculinity and I'm all in
favor of masculinity great many other
people have categorized it as toxic
masculinity because of the misogyny and
so on do you feel that maybe you have
collectively gone too far in the
misogyny and that has been again one of
the reasons you find yourself in the
problems you're in well again when I say
first of the kind of alpha male well
what have I said what have I said that's
no I'm just asking you generally whether
you feel that's part of the problem I
don't I don't think that's part of the
problem I don't think it is a problem at
all I think that when somebody has speak
been speaking on the internet for a
decade you have to understand that first
of all lots and lots of content is
produc and it's very easy to cherry pick
and to take things out of context and
number two the man speaking on the
internet 10 years ago is not the man
sitting in being interviewed by you
today you know who I was when I was 25 I
fancied myself a bit of a dating coach
used to give people advice on how to
meet women and how to pick that's not
how I Live Now I'm 35 I'm not 25 you at
25 I'm sure were very vastly different
than you are today
so you know I don't think there's a
problem with anything I've said because
I've never advocated for anything
illegal I've never advocated for any
crime I do not advocate for drugs I do
not advocate for violence I do not
advocate for any of these things so if
Andrew said that women can't drive as
well as men once like it's very easy to
jump on that and say this man is the
world's biggest misogynist because he
said X and I think it's he said a he
said a lot worse things than that I I do
think that was that was the original
reason he I do think he said a lot of
blatantly misogynous things I don't
think he's even really aware I don't
think he even thinks they are misogynous
well that depends on your worldview and
it actually depends on the worldview of
where you live because if you were to
walk around the country of Romania the
great country of Romania and you were to
talk to people and say some of the
misogynistic things you've heard Andrew
me anyone else in the world say in
England that are considered misogyny the
men and the women here would be like
yeah huh what misogynistic what what's
like that does that's not a very good
defense well no it's not the fact that
other countries I'm I'm not trying other
countries Toler it no I'm not trying I'm
not trying to defend myself but the man
should go out and work and the woman
should stay home and take care of the
family this is my point so in England
that's for some reason makes people's
heads explode when I say that's how I
want to live I'm happy I'm not saying
you're perfectly entit to live how you
like absolutely you guys have made
millions of millions of pounds out of
preaching that message and the and the
criticism is that young impressionable
teenage boys in particular have been led
to believe by you guys that the only way
to succeed in life is with that Dynamic
where the man in charge he's the hunter
he's the provider the woman stays at
home she makes herself look good and she
her only whole modus operand each day a
whole raise on debt just to get up and
make a man feel good I'm going to
correct you because I think you're
completely wrong about what me and
Andrew preach what me and Andrew preach
is a message of masculine excellence and
when you are an excellent man when you
are strong Smart Sharp all of the things
that we tell young men to be disciplin
then you can find a wife and a woman and
a life and a dynamic for wives if you
like and live exactly how you want I
don't tell yeah and you can have a wife
who's more successful than you dat a
judge or a la you both basically believe
women should stay at home and not go to
work no I I believe that I want my woman
at home with my family and that's the
way I wish to live however that's also
what you preach that's also what you
preach in your University right I mean
you you you think I I Don't Preach
anything inside of any University right
well okay no the no the university sorry
if you're talking about the real world
the the online educational platform
which has been attacked and slandered
more than me keep in mind I don't own it
it's been slandered and attacked said
that it teaches people how to abuse
women what kind of app would teach
people how to abuse women it's insane it
teaches web design e-commerce
copyrighting cryptocurrency trading
basic methods of wealth wealth creation
and that's it it actually has nothing to
do with teaching anyone anything about
women to the point that women are
members the war loads of members sub the
War Room well the War Room doesn't have
female members no I can explain why that
is if you care but I don't think it's
that a reason well I I would say that I
don't have or my brother or any of the
men in the War Room don't have any
business telling women how to be women
you see we're not misogynists if we were
to get women into a group and say hey
women you need to be like this you need
to be like that no Andrew Andrew tells
women how they should be all the time
including a lengthy tweet I read I read
to him it was only last week and that's
my point I read the whole tweet for a
reason is it went on and on and on and
honestly it was just blatantly
misogynist yeah but people can take that
or leave it this is Twitter that's a
public it doesn't make it not misogyny
well you misog and here's where your
massive reach influence becomes
problematic to me because I see on the
streets when I walk around in London in
particular the number of kids who come
up to me all star eyed about the tape
Brothers right and they're like you know
top G and blah blah blah blah blah but
they're being conditioned to think by a
constant rhetoric mainly from Andrew but
I don't think you're particularly that
different in your worldview of how
women's place in the world should be
that they're led to believe that if you
know if a woman wants to go to work
there's something wrong with that and we
we're in a very different place now to
where we were in the 50s you know a lot
of women love going to work love their
jobs they're successful often they may
be the main Breadwinner in the family
right the whole dynamic has changed
there's no suggestion that there's a
repeated patent of women that go to work
that have unhappy marriages or lives or
unhappy children no but I believe
Society has gotten much worse in the
last 30 40 years and I because of women
going to work no not because of women
going to work because of men losing the
agency to discipline the children in the
household and to be seen as the
figurehead now that's my personal
opinion and if find it misogynistic
that's completely fine but I will say
that on places like Twitter what I won't
do is get any young man personally or
speak with young men personally in a
personal conversation say Hey you need a
woman who you could control and can't go
to work and stuff that is absolutely not
what we do I think Ricky J's made a very
interesting point about people putting
something on Twitter and people taking
it personally like it's written for them
it's not written for them Andrew can
live the way he wants to live and let me
tell you me and Andrew live in very
different ways in regards to the the way
we see relationships Etc because we are
both very different people but he can
live the way he wants to live because
one him and his girlfriend are both
consenting adults and that's their
prerogative two he's achieved a level of
success and and masculine Excellence
where he has the choice of picking which
type of women he wants to date I like
different types of women you've achieved
masculine Excellence yourself piers and
you I'm sure have a very happy
relationship with whichever woman is in
your life yeah but I I actually I do
believe masculinity is important and I
don't like the way it's always
constantly reframed as toxic great we
agree but but I do think that the
constant stream of misogynist statements
but I'm talking mainly about Andrew but
the constant stream with them I'm not
even sure he's aware of how they come
over that's and that was clear from our
interview yeah well again and people
could take what what's put on Twitter
and they can either apply it to their
lives or not they can take it personally
or not I don't know how many followers
Andrew has on Twitter millions millions
of millions people million he's not
writing it aimed at women or aimed at
men or aimed at anybody is well he's
voicing his own opinions about how he
lives his life but to a massive audience
to a massive audience a and then you
guys do your YouTube stuff and that has
a massive audience on Rumble not YouTube
YouTube I'm sorry you're banned from
YouTube right but you're on Rumble
you're banned from some platforms you're
allowed on you're allow back on Twitter
and so oned um you know it's a look I
just think it's for me when I look at
all the rhetoric the stuff that I find
most problematic to use the phrase of
the the buzz phrase of our era
absolutely it's simply where I feel like
if it Strays into that misogyny I think
you let yourselves down that you have
you have a good message in many ways you
know a lot of the stuff not withstanding
the serious charges you're facing and
we'll have to see how that all plays out
and maybe you both are very different
people to the ones you're claiming to be
we'll find out right but in terms of
your general rhetoric I find that
constant running underpinning theme of
misogyny and about where A Woman's Place
should be that is the problem in terms
of the influence on young men they
shouldn't all be walking around thinking
that A Woman's Place is only in the home
serving their men and that somehow their
only thought process each each day women
should be how do I please my man not can
I get a fulfilling job or any of those
things but no you stay at home
self-improvement make yourself look good
obey his instructions all that kind of
stuff but Andrew talking about the way
that he wants his relationship not it's
not it's to what advocating and forcing
the whole world to see way yeah but
that's the delusion because well no
because he you can say he only wants
that for himself right by the way he's
allowed any relationship he wants but
when you pretend that when he says those
things they're not Amplified to
literally tens of millions of young men
but here's why you're wrong then you
know that's not true well here's why
you're wrong because you assume that
Andrew tapate for some reason in this
conversation is the only influencer in
the world and the only people uh person
people listen to because he's not at all
the internet I tell you he's one of the
most influential no he absolutely is and
that's great and that's the part of
that's the part of his influence that I
think is a potentially Mal and it's
wonderful and good and you don't have to
like it but let me tell you each every
Force has an equal opposite for
somewhere else so on on X Elon has now
legalized free speech on that platform
so there are differing opinions on every
single um on every single aspect of life
including how you want to date women
what kind of music you should listen to
what kind of cars are good what kind of
whatever it is so for every Andrew Tate
out there there's some feminist only
fans model who lives in Florida who
makes rap music who's saying that men
are nothing and Men AR so the people who
are listening to Andrew T aren't
listening to Andrew T they're listening
to the internet as a whole and I believe
Andrew's message is one
overwhelmingly positive absolutely
overwhelmingly positive and I believe
he's a very important mark on that
spectrum of opinions that exist out
there because when you delete Andrew
Tate the mean average of people will
drift down this toilet of degeneracy and
become less like Andrew Tate he's a
professional athlete with a with a
completely clean criminal record by the
way um who's massively financially
successful who's kind who's generous he
runs his own charity he's the best
brother he's the best father he's the
best uncle he's an absolutely wonderful
men and I would love to see more men
become like him so I like his opinions
and I like the fact that he's out there
Tristan
tight thank you it's been a
pleasure